[Music]
well the massacre in parkland Florida
last week has not surprisingly sparked a
renewed push on the left to take guns
away from American citizens the new call
is for a ban on so-called assault rifles
that's an intentionally imprecise term
that includes ar-15s and a lot of other
sporting rifles bans have any kind tend
not to be popular but Americans are so
upset many of them by the school
shootings and rightly so that they might
be open to a ban if it promised to save
lives so the question is would an
assault weapons ban prevent future
shootings that's the key question and
luckily we don't need to guess about the
answer we already had an assault weapons
ban in this country for 10 years
starting in 1994
now that law wouldn't was written
mandated a comprehensive study of its
effectiveness which was produced so we
have a definitive answer according to
the Justice Department our assault
weapons ban the one that passed in 1994
had no effect on crime rates none
nobody was saved by it that shouldn't be
surprising if you know the numbers
because despite the hype rifles are
actually not the weapon of choice for
the overwhelming majority of killers in
America in 2015 the most recent year for
which we have data rifles were used in a
total of two hundred and fifty two
homicides in America by comparison
old-fashioned knives sharpened metal
were used in more than 1500 killings
blunt objects killed 437 a striking 624
murders were committed with bare hands
and feet there's the actual numbers on
that from the government so the science
is in on this and it's conclusive and
yet the very people who tell you they
still believe in science and you don't
don't care about the science in this
case they're still trying to buy an
ar-15 a new piece of legislation called
the assault weapons ban of 2017
introduced last year by several
Democratic senators would outlaw the
manufacture the sale or transfer of more
than 200 different quote military-style
assault weapons
what's a military-style assault weapon
well according to the law it's any
weapon that has features like a
detachable magazine a pistol grip a
forward grip a folding stock or the
infamous barrel shroud presumably named
because its purpose is shrouded in mist
for the people who proposed banning it
they have no idea what it is most of
these are cosmetic features by the way
they don't make firearms more deadly
they just look them make them look more
scary and that's enough let's stop
pretending none of this nonsense would
reduce mass killings no matter what
they're telling you the people pushing
it don't even believe it would have that
effect and they'll admit that if you ask
them because it's impossible to deny it
again the numbers are in the real
problem they have the thing that
animates them is loathing of the Second
Amendment which like the First Amendment
they no longer believe in they think you
do not have a right to own a gun and
they're making hard working hard to make
sure you cannot only done their aim is
not safety its control Jumaane Williams
is in New York City Councilmember he's
running for New York lieutenant governor
and he joins us tonight Counsell
Williams takes off coming up thanks for
having me I'm glad we decided it's a
good time to talk about gun safety yeah
it is a good time to talk about a gun
safety I think it's always a good time
so we had an assault weapons ban very
much like the one that Democrats in the
Senate are proposing and we had it for
ten years and we know because it was
studying exhaustively that it saved no
lives so what would be the motive in
reimposing that same law well also I
noticed in your data you didn't put down
that 90,000 Americans or shot 30,000
killed by guns every single year but the
real question what percentage of those
are suicides by the way do
so one people like to put that out back
it matters but two-thirds well it does
matter actually
so we'll say majority were suicides
two-third of suicide but that means
right now 10,000 Americans are murdered
that's one and it went - which is funny
statistics just - which is critically
important all the data shows the
presence of a gun increases a successful
suicide percentage so you think suicide
just as a side note since you're a
liberal I assume you're for assisted
suicide you're suddenly against suicide
what is committed with a gun what's your
position I want to make sure I want to
make sure we're all clear because I know
you're massive inflation and is good and
I just want to make its no you can't say
there are 30,000 gun deaths and not note
that two-thirds were self-inflicted I'm
not I do not for suicide assistant a
physician assistant or otherwise I'm
sure you are but I just want to be clear
with our viewers that no
and say that she were that the the lives
are loss of suicide also matter and the
10 carry murders should be count as well
look I look I'm not for gun killing if
any kind my only point is look
legislators make laws and they do so in
the hope they will have their attendant
effect and we know from 10 years of
experience that an assault weapons ban
doesn't work there's no debate about
that the DOJ came to that conclusion
after studying it so why would we want
it again it's a simple question so but
actually the real question is and it's
always to you tucker do you believe that
we shouldn't have unfettered access to
guns in this country that know what that
means I don't know specifics i lawmakers
who are trying to impose laws on the
rest of us and I try to assess whether
those laws are no if we're both being
honest and want to deal with them I am
being honest and so what we have to
start as a point of where people agree
and what I'm saying to you is should we
have unfettered access to guns in this
country I don't even know that means we
don't have unfettered access over state
that's not easy at all that's a question
I'm trying to get to you so that we can
have an honest conversation about what
to do after we've agreed with that No
okay so let's get wrought rather than
get in this sort of Airy world let's get
into the those words don't mean much
let's get into the specifics of the
legislation that the left the Democratic
Party is pushing now they are saying
that guns that have something called a
barrel shroud ought to be prohibited
outlawed banned again my question is why
why would a barrel shroud make a gun
more dangerous do it again that's the
wrong question the question the wrong
clamor is a point to a question usually
you support unfettered access to guns
that is what the question is and what
you do success with it and it works
because you give people ready and I mean
I'm responding to an actual piece of
proposed legislation in the US Congress
proposed by your allies in the
Democratic Party and I'm asking you
about the details of that legislation it
would propose banning guns that have
pistol grips and barrel shrouds and
bayonet lugs mass killings and bayonets
what is this what you do well is
focusing on something and I'll tell you
so focus on facts right yes on the real
and you refused to answer it is whether
or not this country should have
unfettered access to guns and needless
to say is no we don't allow heroes to
have guns
what should we do because when you look
at something like a car that was made
just to transport people and
accidentally kills people we have
tremendous amount of regulations you
need insurance you have to have training
are we charge on industry regulator on
bond is made to kill people are you
raining to to to purchase a gun in most
of this country are you willing to
address the actual law proposed by our
US senator now the country that has 50%
of all civilian guns in the world and is
4% of the population are you willing to
admit that that has something to do with
the gun violence in this country
it's a nonce look you're not I'm dealing
in the realm of social science in facts
all we butthere's know you're doing
inflation from here both shootings Butch
your I don't want to use the fact that
you're unwilling to address the
specifics of the legislation suggests to
me that your real aim is not reducing
gun violence but something I would say
hidden maybe well the reason I'm running
for lieutenant governor cause in New
York City I've been a leading voice
among others in reducing gun violence
just in the past
what have you done to reduce gun
violence in this country that talking
point but you ought to fire him because
it's not and I look forward to your
Twitter fans in just a few minutes but
there'll be a few people that always
respond to Hanson
because I came on the show and I'm
looking forward to work and start doing
something for the state of free time
manner what happened to my kids that
I'll tell you that I told you what I do
I'm very proud of it I can tell you our
Thank You congressman Thank You
councilman rather oh I just gave him a
job boost